hello everyone welcome back to GameSpot
we are starting our theme of the year
countdown right here today this Monday
morning we're gonna be counting down
every single of our top 10 games
starting out every weekday until the
20th on which we will have three - wanna
I'm here with Pete Brown so Michael hi
um what up we go concepts um hi and I'm
Mike my Hardy me and people beyond all
these hosting it and we're gonna have
guests on that either review the game or
like it or just general experts on the
game again we are gonna be
live-streaming
throughout the coming week and then up
until next Wednesday today we're gonna
be chatting about our number 10 game and
then we're gonna be actually playing it
for a while but without further ado I
will just get into the montage for our
number 10 game here you go
everything that lives is designed to end
we are perpetually trapped in a
never-ending spiral of life and death
glory to mankind Laurie to mankind
[Music]
[Music]
we will never give up our struggle we
will take back the seas the sky the land
we will take back our world from the
scourge of the machines
we will not fail in this mission here
and now we will put an end to this
goddamn war
glory to mankind
is this a curse for some kind of
punishment I often think about the God
who blessed us with this cryptic puzzle
and wonder if we'll ever have the chance
to kill him so there you have it near
automata or automata as I prefer to say
his GameSpot's number 10 game of the
year
Miguel concepción you review this game
back in earlier in the year like first
quarter and a fourth quarter yes
in a nutshell before we get into
specifics what is so great about this
game from yoga taro and platinum games
well it's an action RPG developed by
Platinum Games and if it's uh it's a
first of its kind collaboration between
Yoko taro and platinum and if you know
the type of action that Platinum Games
develops seeing it in this open-world
RPG setting is a rare treat yeah and it
throws it all these philosophical themes
about Android autonomy and humanity too
right conversely Michael I do want to
talk about as far as platinum is
involved tell me what the combat and
like the progression and as far as your
upgrading your character is 9s and 2b
and whatnot yeah
so it's not traditional in the sense
well you gain levels but there's no like
stat based stuff that you would see in
other action RPGs instead there's the
chip system and you can essentially
customize what you're able to do you can
you know get health back is you destroy
other enemies or you can attack faster
move faster different things like that
you can customize and you have a limited
number of slots obviously you can buy
more but you're still limited and I
think that gameplay wise you know you're
gonna get that platinum action that's
like super fast pace it's crazy off the
walls that kind of keeps you engaged but
within that you have the chip system
that you know makes you think about what
you want to do how you want to engage
the enemies and since you get so many
chips to you I often have to think about
what you have and how much space you
have and what you want to be doing yeah
me Galen right here you can see in the
b-roll that it's not just like a
third-person action game all the time
like kind of fluctuates between action
genres like sometimes it's a bullet hell
other times it almost approaches being a
2d platformer can you talk about like
how fluidly it jumps between these kinds
of combat I was very impressed with like
how seamless it is and it just speaks to
the surface unconventional gameplay and
even like narrative approaches that Yoko
Taro's executed even just the amount of
I think the soundtrack is predominantly
vocalized from just uh just these just
the this kind of soaring type of solo
vocals to these haunting chants the
whole game just served this uses in some
unconventional designs but very
approachable at the same time yeah that
unconventional style also carries on
throughout the entire game whether
you're like you can see here what it's
like top-down action then it goes to a
traditional third-person action and then
you have like mech combat and then like
you said with music structure but also
in the way the narrative is told and it
does a lot of there's a lot of neat
things that I don't think is like it
should you should know this going into
the game that you will be there will be
surprises not just like how the story is
told but the things that makes you do
within the story as you'll see later in
the playthrough is that it kind of does
this really neat thing that really
strikes with me was when games take
control out of your hands
to kind of move the game forward or it
messes with what you can and can't do
when you don't know it's coming yeah and
I think that like when you mentioned the
unconventional gameplay style and also
unconventional narrative and you piece
those together and you get something
really special I think yeah without the
talking about spoilers we're not going
to spoil it if you're gonna stick around
for the last room after we might talk
about spoilers but right now we'll avoid
them how does that work in terms of like
the pacing from one play through to the
next actually first of all calling the
plate there is Miguel you were saying is
a bit of a misnomer you want to talk
about that right well yo Kotaro is are
playing with player expectations as to
what an ending is the first time you see
the the first end credits you're really
seeing the end of the first chapter and
depending on like how many endings you
come across
you'll actually end up you can end up
seeing up to 26 endings but there are
five main endings for you to see the
complete picture yeah I'm just gonna say
like that also kind of oh just touching
on it might affect the pacing from one
playthrough to the next which is very
different I mean you do like you will
see things from different perspectives
you might have different abilities as
different people but again we won't
spoil exactly who you play as and what
happens but Michael from play through to
play through how does that affect like
your overall perception the game as far
as like going through it once and then
twice there's any times as this person
or the next I have many feelings about
this but I think hmmm how do I say this
so there's playthrough a playthrough B
or well I would actually call them
chapters like we mentioned earlier
because you don't get the whole picture
within even the second what we call
played through it presents more
questions and answers that I think I
always say that but it really does and
then you kind of pieced them together
the more you play now with the second I
think you should know this going in is
that you know you're gonna have to go
through these three different
quote-unquote playthroughs but it gives
you keeps presenting these different
questions to you like it shows you
things but doesn't give you the answer
and then it kind of wraps up by the
third playthrough so it's it's not a
spoiler to know that but the way in
which it does it is very very special
because like I said it doesn't give the
answers but it gives you the foundation
to kind of look back and everything else
it does and kind of piece it together
yourself like oh snap like that was that
was this reveal this is what this meant
and you know we often play games that
have stories that you know they have
traditional story beats which is fine
like especially if it's well told but if
you're gonna go for this thing you
almost run the risk of like plot holes
or things being like not not hitting
players the way you want them to and I
think they did a yoga tarah and the
people who created this narrative did a
really good job making sure that things
weren't lost on you without being very
overt yeah and then Pete I think me and
you during the game of the Year
deliberations have been asking people
who play like all three playthroughs the
world itself
it's almost seems a little bit bland I'd
say like when you're going from the
deserts to the actual kind of Android
encampments back to the urban
for all that's been you know desecrated
since humans kind of uh uh Androids rose
up and you know like whatever the
backstory it happens to be do you think
that from what you play that the combat
and the narrative actually makes up for
this world or to even like the world to
begin with when you're traveling through
it I actually like the aesthetic for me
this darkness isn't really an issue I
think there's sometimes greatness and
simplicity
I could definitely understand some
criticisms though because it is totally
bland and so in some ways but I just
think you know the the complete mix of
everything that is here to to maybe
focus on something like that is missing
the forest for the trees I'm not using
that saying correctly I don't think yeah
cool I did it alright but ya know it's
it's the sort of game where I think it
really begs you to think about things
and engage in such a way that the
environments probably shouldn't be the
thing you're focusing on and if you are
maybe well maybe you're just looking at
the wrong way yeah I don't know it just
seems so compelling and engaging on so
many different levels that I couldn't
help but fall in love with those things
so Miguel again this game is kind of
tough to talk about without like giving
off spoilers what makes it so great and
what it makes it despite the fact that
it was a packed beginning of 2017 this
game stood out among those games for us
as being memorable but in a nutshell do
you think like the first near was kind
of a cult classic right when people
announced the sequel people like a lot
of people were like oh [ __ ] this is
gonna be awesome really excited about
the people like ok I got to go back and
look at what the first year was about
and then I got to see whether you know
yoga Taro's interests are and of course
we think platinum is the name that drove
me in with the combat but this
collaboration like obviously you think
it paid off I get a nutshell what makes
this collaboration pay off so well in
2017 I think being able to actually play
a platinum game in an open world that's
something we haven't actually seen and
if you're really into yogacara
I mean if you're into Yoko taro as a
result of Nier automata you should even
like check out the Drakengard game that
is technically part of the same universe
it's a game with dragons and the darnay
dragons in this game but in his mind in
his world that he's conceived this is
all from you know his imagination I
think that
as sorry I think that it's sorry
well no Michael I was gonna say like
overall like the actual kind of it's
every time people talk about scheme I've
been making the joke that people kind of
sound pretentious when they say they
really like this game yeah but there are
some like big philosophical themes in
this game do you think that it pays off
do you think that they actually now
they're you think like was it two
narrative lis ambitious so I think it
can go two ways it can either hit you
like like damn that like that's really
impactful this all makes sense to me and
wow I got to be it for me someone who
really likes this game it almost makes
you reflective once you finish it like
let me think about my world and how how
I feel about things or it can just or
you can finish it and be like what are
they trying to do like oh they're trying
to be too far up their own whatever nuts
yeah sure so I think I can go both ways
and in that regard but if it hits hits
you it hits you hard and if it if it
doesn't land with you then you're just
like okay this is like a good action
game but I didn't really like someone
can not connect with these themes but if
it does come like I said like if it does
connect with you it can really hit home
and I I think that they do really
special things with also what it means
to be conscious what it means to be
alive without getting too philosophical
because like often good like cyberpunk
or sci-fi Blade Runner theme yeah so it
doesn't it doesn't ask you the question
of whether or not androids and robots
are conscious know they already that's
already established they are conscious
they do have these feelings so what they
can do is essentially distill human
philosophy distill human conditions and
tell them in a very straightforward way
through androids and robots that makes
you kind of think about like you know
different what the way in which this
world has like different likes societies
and different different collective
communities and stuff so I think it does
a really good job of you know really
making you think about things on a very
granular level without being too too
abstract yeah
and clearly hit a lot of us on
GameSpot's to have really hard in a
fantastic year for releases in 2017
especially the first half in which this
came out this is one of the games that
we really remembered so if you stick
around we are going to be playing that
if you're watching this on youtube or
GameSpot after the fact go back to
GameSpot for all the rest of our game of
the year coverage but in the meantime
let's get to playing it we go we're
gonna have you drive you have had a lot
of experience this game so you do a
chapter select right once you correct
you know you get into it we won't be
playing for I'll see how long we play
for maybe 20 minutes maybe half an hour
to see how interesting because this game
is tough to show in a nutshell as
opposed to a lot of other games that
came out this year cuz like you guys
said it is kind of a long run that this
game pays off and despite the fact that
the combat is very fun in the short term
but yeah this is a where we get you want
to kind of fill us in where you're gonna
be starting from we are gonna be
checking out this amusement park which
this sort of just speaks to the the
surreal nough sub the overall world in
itself you're investigating this this
theme park and you are joined with 9's
your sidekick who's your boy your boy -
I like a lot are you a 2 B fan or a 9 s
fan I've I'm all about to be dog house 9
s is 9 s is cool I mean so is we're
doing spoil or we can talk touch on yeah
but if you are sticking around for the
stream right now which we we really hope
you do if you have beaten this game
otherwise or if you don't care about
spoilers stick around but again we are
Little League this comp gameplay
commentary in a little bit this is your
official spoiler warning yeah we're
gonna more alluding to some things that
do happen yeah to really sell this game
again it's like the go play it for
yourself if you haven't yet and then
come back tomorrow for the rest of our
gaming will be announcing number 9 but
Michael you know like 20 seconds' some
have free rein to talk about what you
want to talk about I'm just gonna say
that 9s really comes around the longer
you play this game the more you see you
kind of sympathize with them in many
ways because of his relationship to 2b
and his relationship to your ha yeah
my huh your hearts all of ours just the
Android organization
y ou HRA what's it stand for I don't
think it stands for anything
I never tells you oh I've been your
guitar oh no oh yeah I'm sure there is
such just like the title of the game is
like capitalized randomly in here
nothing is random you're robbed
everything happens for a reason
certainly back to something we were
chatting about earlier I think what's
really cool is to see a game like this
be able to convey Jonker Taro's sort of
wild ideas but within a game it's
actually fun to play and like pretty
solid like connected to Drakengard
yes but dragon guard games have never
really been like something that you want
to recommend to like to play to someone
else yeah it's like oh you've got to
really be into like this sort of
Japanese game and be able to overlook
these flaws or as platinum delivers
almost such a flawless gameplay
experience that you kind of get into
that first mm-hmm and you're sold on the
game before you really do start to get
to the more philosophical stuff which is
just such a nice pairing yeah like
finally he has the the gameplay to back
up the story that he wants to tell in a
way I remember thank you oh the first
dragon guard played like a very stiff
Dynasty Warriors game yeah right just
like nothing knows nothing interesting
is it's super interesting that earlier
this year between breath of the wild
this and horizon zero dawn all of which
are essentially post apocalypse games
seeing each of them have a different
take on the post apocalypse like
obviously Zelda's is beautiful yet like
evil tinted world and the in high role
obviously horizon is like at once a
post-apocalyptic tale but also a fantasy
game but also just like a sci-fi no not
novel sci-fi game in general whereas
this is just all about the androids in
like what are humans up to and how are
they rebuilding after you know like
androids rose up right the back story is
that Androids it's the typical like
androids turn or no machines took over
and then Androids it's like wall-e yeah
yeah very much more mature well earth
was invaded by alien machines okay
there's my own ease drop machines on
earth
and then yes so then you start off with
androids and humans or whatever on the
moon being sent back to reclaim or think
in small-scale parties which sounds
which is adult premise to begin with but
then of course now they're like these
Lolita dressed Android that makes it
even weirder yeah I think it's funny
because I all see this as the yo ha
units are modeling themselves after what
humans would want them to see them as in
in some strange how abstract winds live
in the fashion district of Tokyo
exclusively first of all what I want to
address Miguel over here who's so we're
in the amusement park where not everyone
is hostile to you some of these machines
are slaughtering them these machines
come here in the like happy-happy a
we're in a like festival we're an
amusement park this is so much fun this
game at this game ask questions about
existing and not existing
Miguel answers those questions yes I
know
damn man you're you're sad is well and
like yeah who you just choose as a sort
actually does factor in to some of the
themes in the narrative yeah like these
right here are are evil because there's
like the people or at the people well
they're not wearing their seat belt on
the roller coaster from one really
dangerous well you know look at this
either you stand right there and
nothing's gonna happen to you so they
are more like sex tinge Disneyland
especially the fireworks beyond your
outfit is sexual everything oh no these
flat shape reminders right
yes about me at least yeah oh speaking
of which the boss fights in this game
Freud Sally yeah talk about the boss
whoa horsey won in shortly but I
remember during the previews for this
game I played it like twice and again I
personally did not play the first year
didn't know much about it until I played
the demo for this game it's like how
should this pique my interest
I knew Yoko taro is but I didn't really
know like all the kind of things he
tries to do but as far as the boss
fights are concerned when I played the
demo of the earlier boss fight against
that massive like crane when you get
when you have
the crane arms that was pretty fun which
course 9s helps you do the hacking but
they're great boss fights I mean we can
see it right here but Michael you work
if you won't shut up about the boss why
do you like them a lot
yeah boss fights are dope because they
they give you different phases in a lot
of them and like for example this is a
good one too because you got a taste of
the hacking minigame in this one so
you're playing as two b9s does the
hacking but once you make it towards the
tail end of this boss fight if you get
hit by it certain there's other units
that drop down and if you get hit by
them you have to escape by playing the
hacking minigame and I think this might
be your first exposure to it because I
remember playing this boss fight and
they're like we got right here so I'm
like what the hell is going on
you kind of have to think on the fly
like what am I supposed to be doing here
and then so you're exposed to this is
how the game teaches you hacking
mini-games just like real life yeah yeah
it's like throws it actually like I'll
figure this out for yourself doc Miguel
you are compared to the first time you
might fight this boss if your plants
game you are very over leveled right yes
this is after how many play throughs or
chapters what everyone say there's after
probably focusing on the the five main
paths plus getting a handful of the
other alternate endings I'm level 50 I
believe this this boss is what well over
70 I know that against real weird
crucified Android left and Roy yeah
Sooners yet here's a this part is a good
example of how the first plate there in
the second playthrough put you through
the same story beats but give you a
different perspective because with this
boss battle Simoni not Mary's dog
Seimone she so you're fighting her here
and you just kind of like oh she's
attacking us she's overcome by this
concept of beauty she wants to be
beautiful and attract another machine
robot but and then you what's he defeat
her you're it's calling oh well she's
done I don't care about her because I
destroyed hers but in the second
playthrough you kind of after hacking
her so many times
you kind of look into her memories and
what she was thinking and you kind of
it's this tragic tale of someone who's
trying to trade chase happiness and like
oh I'll be happy by attracting
and so I'm gonna do all these things to
make myself look beautiful but to what
end
and she just overcome by you know she
ends up going mad by trying to chase
this concept of what humans think of as
beauty and that's why she's so angry in
the end up fighting her is because she's
just [ __ ] wild yo speaking of trying
to attract a mate there's that one part
in the open world
later on after this I believe where a
lot of the robots are like trying to
have sex essentially yes yeah failing
but they just think they need to yeah I
don't know if like that I mean that kind
of factors then like they feel like they
need to be human and continue their
legacy I guess by that right and then
there was one like rockin nothing in a
cradle
there's trying to be human yeah this
whole world is scattered with instances
of robots trying to do what they think
humans would do and that's how a lot of
them are finding meaning is by looking
at like whoa what what did you manatee
do what and chasing those things and man
it's once you kind of piece all those
things together these different society
because there's different societies of
machines within the world of this game
and they all kind of tell these
different styles of of life that we've
seen through human history
like there's the Kingdom so they look to
a king and then there's like someone
who's essentially they look to as a god
and there's like the very hyper
religious kind of thing there's one
that's like this this community of like
everyone's equal almost like socialistic
kind of a society that's very happy and
carefree and then like even more even if
you look at your ha and you play later
in the game and how your ha has this
concept of humans like these are the
people that we need to fight for and it
kind of shows that almost everyone is
the same no matter who you look up to
and that's yeah that's you it's very
chilling in a way so if you had done
that boss fight as 9s you're in this
playthrough he's your sidekick kind of
if you have done that boss fight as 9s
how the dash would have played the same
or would have played out differently
mm-hmm it would have played pretty much
the same except that you have the
ability to hack Seimone which is also a
way to deal damage so as to be you can
only deal damage through like your sword
and your pod
means yeah and then as 9su instead of so
to be has the heavy attack with triangle
but as 9su
triangle like hacks into different
robots and then from there you play that
hacking minigame and then once you
complete it it kind of does like a nice
chunk of damage right and as - I think
that's the most most of the way through
I especially bigger boss battles I did
hacking plus a hacking minigame is
pretty cool until you do it like for the
hundredth time yeah that's what you can
compare that to you like that's Galaga
[Music]
Street Fighter well while we're on that
I guess I'm curious like can we talk a
little bit about maybe where this game
falls short in some respects sure
and unfortunately the shortcomings about
the same system comes pretty early on I
was injured right and right the fact
that if you end up dying in the opening
minutes
I made an opening like half hour you
pretty much have to start start over
yeah was that intentional I mean
obviously it was on their part
intentional in some respects I thought
they just straight up a shortcoming mmm
I think that you know kind of done
something for the players who may may
not be as invested because this is your
first impression an easy way to put
someone on yeah they want they want to
make you question existence right away
they sure do yeah that happened that so
actually I started playing the game was
one of those instances where I thought
it was fully downloaded but it was only
ready to play so I started playing it
when I beat the intro that it's like you
have to wait this long to play and I
forgot it's like maybe it was like the
speed of my internet or something was
would've taken so long and I wouldn't be
able to play anything for like 16 hours
and like well [ __ ] I'll just put this in
standby mode and play on my switch or
something and but then I had to replay
the intro yeah and I could definitely I
would feel a better introduction to this
game because this game the more you put
into it the more you get out of it and
my opinion
and and I have gotten a lot out of at
this point but yeah the smooth start
let's talk about the the DLC real quick
because that was pretty interesting for
this game any play so it puts you it
introduced like an arena mode
Miguel's I read and it lets you fight
like the the CEO of Square Enix like
multiplied himself and would like spawn
like two dozen heads next to rob and it
was pretty difficult as even though I'm
like at the level 50 which is more than
enough to beat the game yeah I think I
probably need to get to at least seventy
eighty two actually we didn't even
unlock the CEO to destroy the seat the
president yeah isn't it a president and
CEO you can fight there's two people yet
this at this point again this is your
first playthrough this is the first time
like what you have perceived as enemy
robots kind of introduce you to their
settlement right or one of their
settlements this is when does this one
have a name of the flag I don't think he
has a name but you do he'll they're like
cash chic style and or settlement oh
yeah this is just to what show you that
hey we're all alike mm-hmm yeah there's
a distinction between robots who are
connected to the network and those who
are not connected to the network as
bonus so it's like the minute to be at
night as you are connected network right
what is the network because we're sure
it's a very good question also I think
you're how units are on their own
network they have like a you are on
network yeah they have a separate ISP so
you know this is an installment dialogue
this is a world where net neutrality
does not exist yeah
so this is a warning to y'all is what
the world's gonna look like it's the
anti net neutrality game Google Fiber
while you can and you run show you
warlord yeah look at these look at these
fools I can't help but look at them
waving flags it's fun they're so cute
Oh machine village is a very literal
name but I guess there's well it's
Pascal's village once you meet the
leader that's the name I knew there's
someone here was let's go yeah it's
reminding me an indoor but also for
fanboys ya know like speaking of
shortcomings I think that this is it's
it's funny because this is written into
the game is that the map system is it
very good yeah they tell you oh we can't
get very good signal down there so the
map isn't gonna have a high resolution
so you can't really tell where things
are and it's like then you kind of
struggle especially with the side quests
which are really good oftentimes I found
myself like is this on a floor above is
this below me like am I in the right
spot I say those parking garages that
have like six levels yeah there was like
a there's a side quests to activate in
that parking garage I'm like what the
like which level am I supposed to be on
and I know it's not the best way to
present the side quests but one thing
speaking about like how not having the
best introduction when I got into the
game and like a way to kind of mention
this just during the segment we're
talking about the game the production
value didn't really pull me in and I
felt like there were some good times
they needed to cut corners but like
again the more I play the more it didn't
care and the more I actually like kind
of was able to ignore it if not
completely just embrace it yeah that's
the word I was looking for it what do
you mean by that like it's like
especially when I first got it's a
sparse look and then especially the
actual I think was the mini-map itself
when I first got into open-world and I
was looking for the resistance
encampment really early on like the
second thing you do after you land sorry
after you do be intro yeah um it just
didn't feel super polished it felt
polished but it didn't look it yeah and
I don't need games to look fantastic all
the time this is I know this isn't like
horizon and this they're like [ __ ]
Crysis 3 or something like that yeah I
did I did feel like there were parts or
like the mini-map epic for example I
just looking at it feels like they did
have to cut corners yeah and maybe like
you mentioned they just decided
afterward to justify a little more
because
the priority yeah which seems weird
because this is like Miguel you were
saying is the first time like Platinum's
gone full open-world you can call it
full open-world there is kind of like
Tomb Raider ish blocks that you have to
totes a Metroidvania is what you're
saying
yeah with very open areas yeah that's a
sandbar it's definitely not a
traditional open world in the sense that
you know what you would think of as like
a far cry or like a horizon where he's
like here are all the side things you
can do and it does have side stuff but
it's it's very very directed like these
side quests are more or less pieces of
narrative not saying that other side
quests and other games are but it's not
necessarily like a checklist where you
can do different things where it gives
you a variety of gameplay opportunities
it's more of like here's some more
context into the world of Nier automata
and what what is actually happening here
yeah I think one of the most one of the
more chilling side quests almost is I
think it's re Miguel do you want to pick
another chapter that might be sure yeah
watch so yeah we made it's a Pascal's
village we saw that all the cute robots
you don't want to fight what would be
another I think there's a there's a boss
fight yeah new boss fires me yeah don't
worry about crazy spoilers too much
maybe you can do the box
what is it the you know anything you
want to go there boy
it's cool a lot of goes and wants to go
deep 9s playthrough this is the very end
of the king okay all right well you
don't have any context I think it's it's
pretty action-packed I think yeah you
kind of uh I guess if you don't know the
context then it just I think it really
like highlights like the soundtrack
definitely and I think it also
highlights the the way in which the game
keeps keeps you on your toes by changing
the gameplay style as well especially at
this any class scene usually takes
clothes off you yeah well you really
notice it when you jump from straight to
the end it's like well you know we need
a fight harder so rip my clothes off dog
but not close off a tower
the tower this is a tower towel Kochi
the time of Babel situation nope
do you guys even know what that is they
got a lot of silence at power yeah no
one knows how to communicate anymore
nobody the peoples of Earth look at this
it's just wild dude wait this is where
also it bounces you back to 9s as a
flight unit so you got a taste of the
flight marry to Guinea plane yeah yeah
you fight some crazy ass eyeballs in
this game as well and as a two we could
say it's a two right yeah a two is
another Android who's essentially gone
rogue but she comes around I think fits
into the story nicely she's gotten Rovi
in what sense broken off from your ha
yeah yeah there are several your ha
units that kind of uncovered the not
necessarily the truth but the nature of
why your hogs is and they kind of said
we don't want any part of that actually
so we're gonna disconnect ourselves make
it short on but you can do that so they
disconnect themselves and they go rogue
essentially and your howl wants to track
them down because they see them as a
threat to essentially what they're
trying to do and you kind of hunt them
down there's some side quests like hunt
down different rogue units and they all
tell you a piece of the puzzle which i
think is why the side quests are so
important because they they're all
pieces to a puzzle and once you realize
their situation towards you like at the
end of this game at the end of this
playthrough you kind of look back and
say whoa like you know there's a reason
why they did this it's not necessarily
it's not traditional sense like oh they
are rebelling against what they see as
an unjust Authority yeah it's a little
bit more than that because it plays with
like AI a little bit and what AI can do
to machines and consciousness and it
sounds all very abstract and
philosophical and it way it is but boy
with all the questions it raises in
whatever answers it does or does not
give do you think there's room for your
guitar to follow up on the concepts he
explores here or is it pretty self
contained in that way
I don't think it doesn't necessarily
leave any like lingering questions he
kind of says what he wants to say right
in the extent to finishing the letter e
and being right once you see all of that
it's kind of like okay everything makes
sense here there any emails give you a
little bit of a cliffhanger but it does
give you a sense of there's more - there
could be more to this but I think that
there aren't any other questions that I
have after like oh I really want to see
like this happened it's more like right
I've seen everything that can happen
it certainly sounds of the game gives
you a lot of variety yes in action yeah
as a lot to chew on I know it like heart
on this a lot maybe hearts the wrong
word is something it's positive but like
telling people to play this game
obviously like the narrative and the
actual thing that does to screw with
that narrative are super appealing in
the long run through the short term
you're not just a platinum combat how
good it feels like here in the
third-person action but the thing I felt
it was like I'm continually continually
impressed with how easily the game just
switches between like third-person
action than 2d like run-and-gun almost
and then what Miguel was just doing kind
of a almost bullet hell shooter at
Eagleburger yeah and the way it actually
goes back that I something like that
that's non rails but this gives you
somebody yeah but it's also fluid and
that it's just pretty amazing to see it
yeah you don't have to like recalibrate
your your mind it's like oh I'm playing
this type of 9ss that's a hey hey that's
pretty good yeah should have that
there's a lot of like fourth wall
breaking that I think a lot of your fans
will enjoy yes although speaking a
battle gear I like I feel like this is a
very it touches on that some of this is
like the same things that Metal Gear
does with like abstract like fourth wall
breaking and kind of the way it tells
stories especially when I think about
Sons of Liberty does some things they're
similar to Sons of Liberty definitely
like give a nod to Kojima really smell
up here with like I think the rhyming
the game came out you could buy like a
little like 99
like $2 pack of skins for your little
senti little robot limited pods right so
you can get like a cardboard box oh yeah
uh whatever some ways it breaks the
fourth wall you call any specific
examples right now does it literally
come out and say hey you're playing a
big game yeah nice yeah towards the end
like I think okay
by the third playthrough there so
there's some of that and also like wait
I mean aside from going into the hacking
and sometimes unexpectedly
there's also it also plays around with
your hide your some at some points of
the game where you have no control of it
it gets it turns on filters that you
didn't know existed in the game you know
yeah in a way that also like kind of
[ __ ] things up when towards the end of
like the second playthrough or the third
playthrough like when you're trying to
like trot along and then you're like
moving slow and then it's like
constantly like going back and forth
between you moving slow and then moving
at a normal speed I thought that was a
little too much
you mentioned the pods that we had
effect in the combat a lot in terms of
your power moves means is that the right
way to phrase it yeah I think that's a
right now you're just essentially what
is when you have equipped right now I
Miguel I know you're busy and so if the
chain gun yeah Linga um yeah you could
you modify your pods some do sort of
like homing attacks but you know it's
the firing rate is less but get up
missiles the fire powers down ya know so
you just did like well-timed dodge is it
kind of like we work to you and stop it
looks really cool too and you're like
cartwheeling and dancing around while
you're fighting there sometimes that
like will spin a sword or a spear around
you yeah those are anyway yeah
wait you don't like they're challenging
but there's like annoying to kind of
like dance around
man this get like it does a lot of cool
things like animation the way in which
9s to be and a to move like the way you
dodge and the way you like glide across
the world and the way you swing your
sword it just it really it really makes
you like really like these characters in
the way
you know characterize them and give them
a little bit of like backstory is like
how these androids work it's pretty damn
cool like look how look how cool that is
I don't stick my sword in the ground
like taught you and I'm gonna whip your
ass trashcan yeah oh yeah they're cute
though we got where you can do you swap
between different weapons all the time
and you kind of stick to a select few
that you were upgrading I like my blades
and sort of like the sword design I
think it was just sort of like a
personal preference but I sort of tried
to find a balance between what I like
aesthetically and also preferring
whatever had like the most high attack
power sometimes came down to that and
there is a mild upgrade system here you
kill yourself and there's an upgrade
system where you could buff your your
favorite weapons and you do that pretty
much what the whole the very non
sequitur not a non-sequitur but speaking
of a PSX just happened they had that
teaser or no game or they had that
teaser with people are hoping it's
blood-borne too it almost reminded me of
blood-borne or how like Souls games let
you upgrade your weapon like oh yeah
like specifically periodically
throughout the game rather than just
like collecting this many like credits
that you pour it I don't know Eisley
credits that will run to you know my
mine or something like but you collect
these specific items that like
blood-borne is like you get the the
shards or chunks or whatever yeah and a
parallel to like Dark Souls and
blood-borne is that the weapons also
have a story to them each time you
upgrade it tells you a backstory of like
the origination of the origin of each
weapon and some it's kind of like some
of its funny-ish it's like silly some of
its also like very dark and haunting
yeah especially at 9:00 essence weapons
I didn't get to upgrade everything but I
was very interested in where it was
with that because like many things in
this game the weapons and the side
quests and the people you meet the
things you do it all kind of builds this
it's a lot of world building do you like
do you use a specific sword for the
whole game and then at the end of the
fifth playthrough they tell you oh this
was once used to kill infants that bet
you feel bad that you did I feel bad no
did you feel bad that you were using a
weapon to kill babies no not at all we
should thank you nothing you got this
game yeah but things got lost on me die
bad
okay out of curiosity so how many more
faces this boss have are you like it's
like twenty closing it on the end or now
I think we're getting towards okay near
the end you don't have to actually get
the health all the way down yeah maybe
it goes into like a final final phase
okay
and I think that's not too far off from
here you actually can only kill it with
potions those ones hot man-hater one
nothing like old Final Fantasy games at
that excited Leo you can only kill the
undead at Phoenix down yeah against me
alright thank you Mike I thought fair
die hey I'll play more file fancy old
ones go in well the robots have snow
climbing is an hour it's so it's a long
ass tower man oh who does it go to the
moon that's a very good question
does it go to heaven I mean anyway if
nothing else this doesn't show what I
was talking about how it switches
between perspectives and your honor I
was just within this specific boss yeah
really keeps the gameplay fresh because
I don't think I would want a
hack-and-slash
for an hour straight I don't think so no
no you're a pretty high level you can
get through this you can apply them
games
vanna three oh yeah
anymore a very nice surprise as was the
announcement that two and one are also
coming this way yeah yeah I thought like
you know Reggie being very stoic I
thought the reveal if they're up being
at 3:00 was like pretty cool you're just
like oh yeah by the way we got some more
for you that's like it's stoic the word
you would use to describe Reggie
or like Barney about us or he's a gentle
giant astir polish sense of foreboding
look at the screen like kicks the [ __ ]
out Percy but um pods man pause the dope
I think can we check out we can't check
out pods right now yeah you need that
show us that quake and then play a
little more it's boss fight them all I
call it a day pod programs only 42
percent this is one game took me a while
to start figuring out oh yeah here's the
chance like I don't think I have figured
out the chip system come oh yeah I mean
I used it but you have these slots here
that basically you can use to customize
your character and for the purpose of
this stream I shouldn't take up so many
slots with your XP game but things like
you know increased maily maily defense
and increasing your tag and smokey
attack I was it's a color-coded bar and
you're right can you like so these ones
you're in right now cuz you ostensibly
use a bunch of those that take up less
space or do you have to like are those
uh those pinkish colored upgrades in the
bar in the middle but those like that's
worth more space or it is just like a
specifics it's like films could the
color coding is different categories
yeah you know some is melee some are
passive some is the HUD um you know you
don't need to see you know the enemy
life bars but one is actually an OS chip
which is spoiler if you actually remove
your OS because actually creates one of
the other endings yeah one of that cuz
you don't
so especially okay so these smaller HUD
upgrades that are showing up as those
small brown slits if you're to remove
all those would you have space for
another bigger pink upgrade yes oh yeah
and I think
that's a way of doing a no hut mode Oh
almost because of those those are all
yeah those get new indicators what is
the ending if you remove your OS chip
it's just one of those it's one of those
gag endings where the credits scroll
like super fast and you've just taken
back to the beginning screen but you
have the chip system I was looking at
you can your setup your setup as a I'm
like I say whack that's mean player that
I'm so are you sort of like doubling
down on your strengths or do you want to
be like really diversify yeah I think
that for me also with the chip system is
that it gives you you can play we
mentioned this earlier you can play the
way you want depending on your chip
setup and different ones take up
different amounts of slots so in a way
you have to think about like what am I
gonna prioritize during this phase of
the game it's an added layer to the
third-person combat which is why there
is you can you can customize loadouts
yeah there's the other side you get
three load outs right and your primary
secondary weapon right yes I know the
ones are tied specifically one
categories just however you equip them
yeah if you want to have that on Troy's
drawn triangle as your heavy attack then
it'll do a little bit more damage yeah
so that's a chip system chips are cool
adds another layer to the game one of
the key tips though is like if you once
you destroy an enemy
it'll they'll give you health back I
think that was key to you know towards
the end of the game or not like a player
recover a little bit depends on what
level of the chip is so the higher level
chips will give you more health if you
destroy it robot and I think in the
third playthrough chapter that was
really key when you're fighting heavier
enemies on a lot of them some of those
battles can drag on a little bit and
they only almost become like bullet
sponges so you can almost see here and
some of those attack upgrades and range
attack upgrades come in handy if you
want to cut those battles a little
shorter
but yeah also pods you can upgrade the
pods so that with bossfight this would
probably take even longer if there's
your first time sure right like what
love you finish the game at your first
playthrough we go power level 40 yeah so
yeah there's an example of like these
fights can last a while they do become
bullet sponges in a way but depending on
your putt your pods you can use the
missile upgrade I think is very
effective for situations like this
missile the fire missiles from your pod
yeah
and does a little bit more damage so
here we go over again we are we have to
talk the tower I think we got one more
phase with - maybe okay no I think this
is the is one 5x yeah so here's another
way in which the game throws a different
gameplay element at you
I heard Gundam characters yeah there's
almost like zone of the enders yeah yeah
yeah that's swing
yeah there's only Ender's you know I
know y'all bought that game seeking at
the MTS to demo based seconds only
owners is actually pretty decent yeah
even even today but the man I was
playing the VR upcoming game now the
movie is the movies with Ender's Game
[Laughter]
could you would directly start Norman
Reedus oh man man that's true but there
may be inside this robot oh man that
would be cool what if what death
stranding is like the next step for the
met the true ending to this game seeing
as how Drakengard had dragons and then
teleporting you to another universe no
there'll be serious up here the baby's
the one controlling
oh man no piousness control all of us
beat it down to it
VI man that's what's up
that's all I'll say about so this is
deep thought this is not the last phase
no I think what was oh yeah here we go
evil eye balls slide to the leg a
sceptic I know they're on set the guys
the YouTuber destiny the I saw this
century what the hell are they called
no you're talking about servitor no sir
Barry yeah yeah I feel you on that but
yeah we're not grinding for XP and loot
here
skill meter I see that word sense though
the circular thing and the pod does your
cooldown further for the special attack
that you have oh man this is hey there
we go at the Miss large nose wait is
this it this is it this is it no it's
not it yet oh you should have turned it
down too easy and just like blew right
past all these there's a lot of people
say to just tone it turn it down to easy
and just like blow pass through the the
game it's on the game itself so you can
see all the story bits but I played all
normal I think that some people didn't
like Wolfenstein yeah
I think you know you can do that I think
you'll get you'll still get the most
important parts out of it I think like
going through all these battles and how
arduous they can get you've got a few
gotta feel the weight of your challenge
ahead of you you got to feel the
struggle of these androids this house
entire unit is anybody by the towards
the end of the third playthrough you
really get a sense of like how tired
everyone is of fighting this damn war I
mean the first thing it says the 14th
machine war yeah
and yeah how far in the futures are
supposed to take place by the way 1194 5
1945 that's what sir that's not the
future that is eleven ninety five years
ago wait what did I miss
this is this [ __ ] happen wasn't in
the Bible
Socrates conveniently skipped over this
if you put somehow they know all of
these philosophies these robots the
Aristotle's they were all actually
Android fanboys of angles o ankles
Nitschke
nice yeah this game is very nice sheep
that's black on I watched after I finish
this I went down the rabbit hole and
watch like a 20 minute video that tries
to connect Drakengard one Drakengard
three near and of this game and boy that
was some mental gymnastics you have to
do yeah for that I think you botched it
I watched it okay whoever created
cashing it in right now I know I'm
getting shots out to her she made it was
like 20 minutes I got what was called
but it was pretty dope thinking about
because that I think if I recall
correctly one of the endings to
Drakengard one feeds into Drakengard
three which one of the endings from
there feeds into mirror but it's not one
of the main endings and they played off
that and it's all in a way it's like
almost you don't have to play those
games to enjoy this so if you're
thinking like oh there's this first New
Year game should I play that like nah
just go into this straight up more of a
shared universe and yeah anything that's
a good way to put it is the first near
comparable very comparable in terms of
gameplay super different though super
different without platinum involved
completely
correction yeah and then they did some
weird things with that game to work for
the Western audience they released the
game with a lead character that was made
to look more like brutish and like
cro-magnon where it was it more you know
if you're like an effeminate like male
character in Japan they had two versions
of the game in Japan they did yeah yes
we only got the wall with the with them
with the partition what did I say
cro-magnon because his girls were cute
as hell yeah the thing that was that
mere gestalt and then near replicant was
the Japanese one Evan :
cro-magnon eyebrow me too I got like
really strong bro bow-bow-bow bro bro
bro bro bro brow Bravo
there you go so I might be a descendant
of Pro Magnus but we are we are a direct
descendant should I came straight from
the oh yeah something like that yeah
are you are we there yet close look at
the core into the health bar coach flows
out the stream right when you kill him
already would that be the end of the
game on the build a while there's a lot
more game after that match I thought
you'd say a lot more I don't see a lot
more not a lot less it's heavy though
it hits you with a lot of a lot of deep
[ __ ] so there we go alright watch this
oh look how cool a - looks so badass
like a 9s with this PvP here deep in
Highness becomes pretty cool yeah Oh Oh
things have shifted dramatically they
can see now yeah yeah I think that's
also uh blindfolds are off they can
finally see the truth
a team who had a blindfold off the
entire time so she knew the truth
I'd be it's time to call it yep all
right sweet Miguel thank you so much
great no problem
thank you for especially considering you
were talking as well that was pretty
impressive
so that was later on in Nier automata
and again that was GameSpot's
number 10 game of the year again for
each weekday we're gonna be announcing a
new one and then December 20th we're
gonna do a mega stream with our number
three game a number two game and our
singular game of the year but until then
stick around we're gonna be doing that
all throughout next week and thank you
so much for joining don't check out more
about Nier automata
Miguel's review from back in the year
and then we talk about a DLC stream that
we did we come to seen a lot and you can
go check it out if you haven't played it
go try it out of course GameSpot voted
it's number ten in a fantastic year but
again stick around the rest of the
weekend next week and we'll be showing
off more games
tomorrow's number nine same time 10:00
a.m. Pacific we'll see you then
you